last time we looked at the problem or
the great advantage if you like of using
intermediate codes as a staging point in
our compilers and we spent a lot of
effort talking about how to improve your
compiler but still on the same machine
but with an intermediate code step I
would strongly advise you to watch that
video first because what we're now going
to find in this next one we're doing is
we're just changing the rules slightly
instead of B star improved a binary
we're moving from B prime to B Double
prime we are generating a different
binary for a completely different
architecture but we are using the front
ends that we've already established that
gets us as far as intermediate code what
we're now talking about is how can I
produce a new back end and you will find
that the diagrams I draw are remarkably
similar to the ones on a single machine
for improving yourself so do watch that
one first unless you're absolutely sure
that you've taken every single thing it
said and then we can go on the adventure
of just how intermediate codes are
pretty well vital for porting compilers
in the last video we use this as our
home base if you like our master
referral point for everything that we
were trying to do we had source codes
for two vital pieces and then compile
the versions of them over here what
we're going to find with this one is yes
we'll still be having an H compiler
written in H producing intermediate code
the thing that's going to change this
time is instead of saying things like
take my intermediate code and write a
compiler for e that produces B prime
I'll be saying take that write it in
high-level language of your choice but
make the binary of produces B for a
brand new machine that we can't wait to
get some software working on so that B
prime will start becoming B double prime
and whereas in the previous episode we
were obsessed with getting really high
quality B prime and we got to B prime
star even better we're not gonna be as
obsessed this time with improving the
quality of any binary although that's
possible in the end what we are
concerned with is this time saying I
don't want better binary for the old
machine I want some brand new binary be
double dashed for the new machine and I
don't care how rubbish it is initially I
just want to get some binary for the new
machine working and established what we
can say about any cross compiler is it's
gonna look like this it's gonna be a
chosen higher-level language it is going
to originally be written in B prime but
it's going to produce B
double prime and if you want an actual
example referring back to previous
episodes for this we were in a situation
where our H would see the original
binary it was running on on a PDP 11 and
our beep double prime over here was z80
binary so there you are then that's a
generic form of any cross compiler
there's my actual example of my first
encounter with cross compilation the
bigger question is how does this help
you if you start saying well instead of
just sending boatloads of code across to
that new now we no real control over
what happens if I want to sort of you
know yeah I would did think of it in
those terms send an expeditionary force
onto the foreign machine set up a few
outposts do a little bit more on the
foreign land
than just unload the binary that's been
sent on a boat actually set up a binary
factory on your newly conquered land you
say well yes and actually I mean
intermediate code helps that this is the
one new piece of software you need to
write since everything is working to
intermediate code now it's a
non-optional intermediate stage your
front end of your compiler
we'll quite carefully be producing I all
you need to do to get something started
on your new machine is to write
something in a high-level language which
takes intermediate code but produces be
double dashed at the other side so
that's your intervention point let me
say again it is a worthwhile step to do
because the difference in detail between
a pdp-11 binary and a zhe binary is
pretty considerable and if you don't use
intermediate codes you have to go right
back to square one and think oh I've got
to create a binary from scratch all over
again but I'm gonna get in there in that
code generator trying to throw the old
one away you say is there anything I can
learn from this and just out of nowhere
bridge the gap between your high-level
language and your new be double dash
which you got what we're saying is it's
a lot simpler if you break it into two
parts leave the front end as it is on
the other machine for the moment and
it's producing I like man what you need
is a new back-end so we're in a
situation now that as I've made clear
any cross-compiler is going to be
running on your old machine to start
with producing binary code for some
other new machine so what we've now got
to do is revisit all we did before we
said here's how the transformation chain
works with intermediate codes if all you
want to do is to improve the quality of
the coding for your home machine be
prime this is similar but different now
we're going to say instead of producing
better quality binary for this home
machine we want to produce brand-new
binary but for a foreign and different
machine and we want to know exactly what
processes were going to have to go
through similar to before but a little
bit different in detail so hold tight
this is what we have to do we've got
this new piece of software something
that takes an intermediate code we know
the spec of that we can ratchet in HR
chosen high-level language it's always a
good thing
but we know that eventually that thing
has got to be compiled out
- binary but it's going to produce be
double - we take our new piece of
software and we compile it now notice
that is my original h2 intermediate
compiler that runs on the old and the
same but I'm using it to compile this
new thing we know what we're gonna get
and I write it out up here H gets
translated into I via this so we are
going to end up with I be double - but
the H has gone through 2i so we've now
got a piece of software that takes in I
is running on high but produces beatable
- don't forget that there is as the
fourth component in our chain always
available to us an intermediate code
compiler that takes it down to binary
now we want back from the beginning of
time the original component number four
which is that so I've written an AI
interpreter in our it produces b-double
- but from work on the old machine I've
got something that takes AI runs on B
prime or B - produces B - net result of
all of that what do we end up with we
end up with I be double dash B dash so
that is the result if you like of
compiling the intermediate code right
down to binary we've now got a really
well it is close to being wonderful but
not quite it's an intermediate code
compiler it produces super duper newbie
double dash for the new machine slide
rollback is it runs on the binary for
the older machine so we're almost we've
established our bridgehead but we're not
quite invaded yet because what we'd love
to do is to get this thing down here
saying be double dash it's just a
question again of feeding the right
thing back into itself we've got our
written in are producing B
- we've compiled that with an AI B - B -
and we've ended up with this
intermediate code producing b-double -
written in V - what do you do now that
you've got this executable answer final
stage feed it back to itself take the
original thing and do it one more time
if you could take this look I I beatable
- and feed it into your newly created
binary I running on B prime own how are
let trumpet sound you are finally
achieved what you wanted to achieve
which is that goes through there and you
end up with AI B Double Dash
B Double Dash in my original set out of
pieces of componentry you need I had one
two three and four and looking back at
it now what we have got is that this is
the equivalent of for look back in the
early days when we only had one machine
you had needed an AI compiler to take AI
into binary prime binary Prime there
what we've now done with all this
jiggery-pokery with T diagrams is we
have produced ourselves and I be double
prime B Double prime it is totally on
the new machine now it doesn't rely on B
Prime at all now again those of you
whose soldiered how should we say really
soldiered hard on the previous episodes
of this will now recognize that this is
the same old story you want to have the
binary you are running on being of the
same quality as the best binary you can
produce except now it's not so much best
binary it's new binary rather than
generating new binary for the new
machine off the old hardware can you
feed yourself back to yourself enough so
that eventually you end up with
something that is totally happy on the
new machine and doesn't need old machine
support in terms of B prime at all
anymore so that's been a bit of a
marathon folks we've we've mounted our
galleys we've invaded the distant shore
we finally had enough cold compresses in
our head that we think we're clear what
we've done but if you just go over this
carefully for yourself and draw yourself
lots of T diagrams or better still make
yourself some T diagram shapes and just
experiment with them until you're quite
happy with with what you're doing and I
hope it's been convincing that although
it is messy at times it is so much
easier when you move to a new machine to
say all I need to write to get myself
going is an intermediate code compiler I
don't need to redo the whole chain that
can be backfilled as we go along but I
could take the existing front-end and
port it into a being a new front-end
simply if I've got the back end tools
that can produce be double prime for me
it's as simple as that really so an
executable binary the net effect of
slotting that T diagram
against here slightly downwards is to
show you that the C you've written gets
converted into binary and the net output
from this process it produces out a
program that you probably store in a